let's multiply 4 times 2012 actually
let's make it a little bit simpler let's
multiply 4 times 201 just to just to
simplify things a little bit
4 times 201 so as we've seen in previous
videos I like to write the larger number
on top this is just one of many ways of
tackling a calculation like this all
right the 201 and then I'll write the 4
right below it and I'll write it right
below the ones place and so I have 201
times 4
now just like we did when we were
multiplying a 1/2 times the two-digit we
do the essentially the same process we
first multiply 4 times the 1 well 4
times 1 we know is equal to 4 so we put
a 4 right over there in the ones place
then we can multiply our four times the
digit that we have in the tens place in
this case we have a 0 in the tens place
so 4 times 0 well that's just 0 4 times
0 0 we put the 0 in the tens place right
over here and then last we have 4 times
4 times this 2 right over here and so 4
times 2 is equal to 8 and we put the 8
right over here and we get our answer
804 now why did this work well remember
when we multiplied 4 times 1 that was
literally just 4 and we've got that 4
right over here when we multiply 4 times
0 that's 0 10 so we got zero tens right
over here and when we multiplied 4 times
2 this was actually a 200 it's in the
hundreds place so 4 times 200 is 800 so
what we're essentially doing by writing
it in the right places we're saying 4 x
201 that's the same thing as 4 times 200
which is 800 plus 4 times 0 tens which
is 0 tens plus 4 times 1 which is 4 so
800 plus 0 plus 4 is 804